hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to mono now according to
this game everything is watching you and
we know what you did you shouldn't have
done that thing how dare you even click
on this video well now that you're here
your only punishment is to be subjected
to whatever the hell mono is all not the
disease I mean I'm talking about this
game here that we're gonna play in the
Mexican just come there we go its it
finally took a little bit hello the
developer of mono here thank you for
buying my game however I must warn you
this game isn't functional have had
reports of it crashing many times I
never got around to finishing the AI it
shouldn't be working but it is and it's
really ok alright I won't blame you
that's the only thing I saw oh good ok
alright
judging by the webbing sounds there's
either a hell a dubstep party going on
next door or I'm about to be abducted by
aliens or I've already been abducted by
aliens and everything is awful hello
hello open you know how about no alright
then I guess that one's just locked what
am I looking at here oh okay
shirts I thought it was giant teeth fair
for a second there ok ah got it
alright cool I'll just get out of my
bedroom which is the most barren bedroom
I've ever seen in my goddamn life I love
my single lamp I love my white
everything
man the weather outside sugar is weird I
don't know what that's all about but
okay hello neighbors I think I might be
trapped in a computer oh okay
well I the only thing I knew about this
game before I got into it was that uh it
was like something about technology and
glitching it seems I might be I'm just
gonna call out in my own house because
that's a normal thing for humans to do
hello any murderers want to kill me
actually you know a power drill murderer
might be preferable to whatever hell is
in store for me
anti is that you huh are you glitching
up the weather outside oh yes
hi it's okay don't worry about anything
don't don't don't ask why I'm saying hi
right now cuz nothing happened you don't
need to worry about a thing
I'm totally fine my computer didn't
crash and then I was scared that this
game was actually a virus it was gonna
be taking over everything that I loved
and held dear that didn't happen at all
let's carry on the game um yeah I don't
even remember what I was saying cuz it
just fought with my computer for about
ten hours I had to pull a graphics card
out because for some reason it just dead
and I didn't know what happened that I
got super super worried about it but
seems to be working now I suppose that's
good
hi okay alright then you don't need to
do that to me for me to me
I keep wondering if the next step is
gonna cause my computer to crash again
it's getting a little old but I don't
want to put her to rest just yet no I
don't want this to be the game to do it
alright then I just take a breather
because man something strange seems to
be going on in the neighborhood maybe I
should call the Ghostbusters I asked my
favorite channel blinding white regret
oh my god what is happening out there
okay so if I'm not mistaken I must be in
a computer simulation and even though
I'm alone in my own home I I'm not gonna
be weird I'm just gonna shout out for
anybody to be there hello
I did not expect the response yeah my
ignoring that for a moment yeah and
maybe you could take some of these take
them with you down to the hellhole that
you came from crawl back in there [ __ ]
yourself okay alright then why is
everything untextured everything is just
pure white everywhere you look
alright fine man I'm brave I can face
whatever that is probably Wolverine
scratching up my door hello knock like a
normal person if you're not gonna kill
me hi okay alright then
hello you having some trouble in do you
feel alone out there where you talking
to be here am I talking to you okay
alright then that's good come on my way
is anybody else out there
I guess stop yelling about things oh
good the blood I ordered arrived I was
wondering with how is good filled is it
gonna flood my house
oh good oh thank you good thing this key
floats on blood I'll just take that I'm
not even gonna wipe it off put that
right in my pocket yeah why I ordered it
[Music]
I'm gonna chance it one more time is
anybody else out there that wants to
kill me huh for the first time we have
silence okay so I got a key I don't
think there was a door up here but like
opening that door that door was to squat
you just Peters calm your damn tits I've
had a rough time here that's honest okay
why did I come in here why why did I
need to unlock this and go in the
goddamn bathroom
I have no reflection [ __ ]
got a piece of me huh
anybody out there want a piece of me I
see something through the gap it's like
some kind of railing or something maybe
more of my own house that I seem to be
trapped inside of so there maybe have
been something in here that I needed
playing it's too dark in here somebody
turn on a light I'm gonna go back
upstairs
better not be any scares waiting for ah
[ __ ] you hi you won't be for long what
alone or alive or slightly moist from
the blood from that key which is it
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] you
that's not my desktop
that's not my desktop at all I think I
would know that huh huh [ __ ]
there's the puzzling P sorry oh hi okay
all right then Oh are we just gonna be
looping through this again and again and
again
is that how we're gonna be doing it oh I
see how you play okay all right then I
think I know why this game might have
crashed my computer it's a boy
[Music]
okay so what do I need to worry about
except for the exact same thing you did
that before didn't you huh I'm a run for
you oh this is open now that's different
maybe I do
oh do I god I thought I something moving
oh I don't like that I don't know if I
saw something or not but it either white
scared me
oh good oh they gave me extra okay then
wow that's nice Lisa bring some color
into my life I open this [ __ ] okay
alright then can you just calm your tits
there I need to collect myself before my
heart explodes [ __ ] off this part
doesn't have the way out also oh hi okay
hello alright okay alright I'm okay with
this how are you doing hey neighbor I
was going do you feel safe ah you know
feel alright feel pretty good
I can see behind the screen okay what's
behind the screen it's the border
keeping me from being free Oh
Yura you're a dark applier wannabe ain't
you
not for long or you anti septic guy no
know what you are but you're not welcome
here
you're not welcome here
[Music]
I don't know what's happening oh I was
here the whole time I didn't go away all
righty then just gonna go back in my
home that I love and don't want to get
murdered in I gotta get murdered in it
in the exact same place before
oh I don't want it ready for it oh the
brave boy Oh what [ __ ] is that
what's that whole way oh don't look for
that mouse to use camera Wow okay now
you see a pal anybody else want a piece
of [ __ ] Wow Argentina
[Music]
OxiClean okay I didn't see anything in
there whoa close out okay retry that
level apparently that's one ever game
death is another way of his escape or
something like that pop up you know I
could just exit out of the game but you
guys want me to keep going okay so the
idea is I think anyway there's nothing
really else really I I don't know this
for certain but it seems like the whole
concept is he's just gonna keep on
trying to get me to die because it said
that every game death is another step
closer for him to get free so if I get
in here blows out maybe if I just oh oh
I hit escape oh hi
[Music]
tonight is the night come find me
I don't know if I want to do that I
dressed a homie to cheese it set that's
my deal night in
I love the screaming you've done with
the place
that's real good decorum oh okay I'm
here all right
oh good I have my camera hello
anybody want a portrait taken of them
click it oh there we go it's got a long
cooldown this one oh man did you combine
a siren to a migraine inducing whoo hi
there I'm not too worried about that
not gonna lie that's a little that's a
little concerning what do you uh doing
there Fido chica you know what I'm not
gonna antagonize that thing because I'm
pretty sure that's probably dead all
right you know what I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go the other way because it was a
hallway okay I got a couch in the way
all right this looks promising I think
it's good okay does have to think is
this the corner the thing is around
there's no idea okay all right I guess
I'm fine
okay here we go then I guess I don't
know okay loser got some semblance of
safety in the form of a toilet even
though that's how I got last time
Shuki I'm gonna go this way by my bed
because that's where I feel safe okay I
got another light this is gonna guide me
oh good it's the teeth all right don't
kill me please I've come a long way I
don't have to go through all this again
I guess everybody feeling I'm gonna have
to do that if I die okay I guess I'll go
left
what was that ooh that looks like that
looks promising
the screams are fading my skin is
clearing up my acne is gone
my spina bifida is cured oh wait never
mind it's all about I'm a horrible
monster [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you it didn't you're a liar you're liar
oh good boot options mono Windows 10 I
want to get out I want to get out okay I
wonder which one is food I'm gonna boot
mono that's what I'd like to what is
that oh it's like a fern half mini game
am i doing that or is it doing it by
itself I can't tell
no I I didn't do that one it's doing it
by itself okay alright that's weird
alright don't know what that's all about
but I'm going to accept this as reality
what happens I can't go backwards okay
well this is weird okay can't get out of
it it's gonna get the high score I guess
Oh think I can jump that one oh my but I
want to get out I want to get out I
wanna get out oh yeah big bubble blowing
baby whiner why don't you get over and
get out yourself why do you need to use
me god damn it the same places before
alright let's see what's different whoa
okay wow that was fast I was not
prepared for that oh I still have this
okay alright then alright anything
different here now step by step huh
alrighty then step by step what that's
bizarre
whoa alrighty then step by step indeed
[Music]
dami you're not probably not gonna see
you again but you're not gonna scare me
again I just want you to know that okay
was I supposed to take a picture of the
other blood thing probably
step by step I made my escape okay hi
you gonna ask me if I feel safe again
the answer is still gonna be yes oh hey
okay that's new oh when did I get this
addition on to my house the spring
weather oh goody goody goody goody okay
here we go skedaddling i'm on the street
now Oh the storms picked up a bit better
I got too much radio interference in my
eye you chose me did I I don't know it's
kind of like a lost puppy situation to
me you entered back in and sacrificed a
bit of yourself
sure yeah okay you will be rewarded oh
oh boy I'm sure this is gonna be good
someday oh okay I'm a patient guy
I
walking down street not doing whole lot
okay all right no lost puppy no no no I
don't want any okay all right there's
something wrong what did I fail that
challenge all I did I kind of old lade
him oh there's more oh there's more oh
boy hey police officers did you know
that the universe is and ding maybe you
shouldn't do something about that or
maybe it's all up to me for some bizarre
reason I was already going in I'm gonna
thank you good thing too good thing the
police officers leave the keys to all
the secure lock ups in their building
right on the front desk you know just in
case anybody needs
I don't know that did hurt a click [ __ ]
you
fine I'll take it give me the key god
damn it [ __ ] you
and thank you any more lockers gonna
fall down on me huh all right thank good
all right what do we got here
hello just where I'm staying
you let me out did I I didn't know you
were in that one you shall be rewarded
at the front doors Oh God
oh why did I come in here then is this
like a metaphorical letting out of a
cage thing
I'm waiting for my eternal reward Jafar
is that you
[ __ ] I knew it I knew that's what I had
to do I knew that's what I had to do I
knew it I knew it
God the running system is really barked
got all my sprinting Nick this Nick
hello did I do it I took a selfie of my
own victory there in the middle of this
jail cell look how great I am I escaped
into a Cell
[Music]
what are you still doing here I don't
know I don't know I'm doing it let's
play did I not warn you I don't know who
are we talking to here who are you my
name is markiplier how you doing nice to
meet you it's me the developer oh cool
let me guess you're trapped in here
because your own creation uh got smarter
than you ever thought it could be and
then escaped and then cause horrible
monstrosity get out while you still can
ok alright been trying to been trying
real hard
oh no it's here I don't have much -
blood splatter oh that's that's nice oh
I have to put a seizure warning on this
cuz whew
alright for your own benefit I'm gonna
look at the ground because that's that's
a lot of things going on there alrighty
then
so I gotta go back in there well what
are we gonna do when I go back I'm not
gonna be able to do anything I'm just
gonna fall over and die I can't fight
this thing
I've got no whoop okay alright then
carry on have a nice day apparently
alrighty then
so is there something new going on in
here that I need to know about oh gee
thank you
this is open that's nice but these are
all closed except for this in this hello
oh hey I need the okay never mind then
well that's gone
oh okay weii this naba I don't know what
Juba Ollie [ __ ] holy hell
hi can I help you I don't want any okay
alright I'm gonna jump off into the
abyss here oh oh okay you tell me that
was the correct answer oh yeah
how did you get here I don't know man I
don't know it's me again the developer
yeah I suspected as much
seems like you're the only way to get
rid of this thing is to kill it oh just
like most things let's get you out of
here first though okay there are three
big buttons in the maze ahead pressing
all three will reset your computer and
allow us to progress but we win it is
also in there
okay all right came on then I guess so
god damn it it ends with a maze what
kind of douchery is this this is a big
button pressed it nailed that one let me
give a high five for myself
good job market blyer keep going get the
other ones ignore the laser flight going
on the sky above anyone else see a big
button out there anybody see it oh I see
another big button mm-hmm
that's a good one that's nice good job
mark lar oh [ __ ] IM fart
[ __ ] goddamn it what are you supposed
to do about that ah titties this is
legitimately my top speed at the moment
trying to go faster but it's not working
yeah it's not working last button baby
oh I'm the best did we do it I don't
know you're the developer you tell me I
ain't got a clue
I'm just trying my best here man just
trying to live day by day day by day no
no it isn't of course not why would it
be check back in the in the full game
with once check back at the for what are
you talking about please consider rating
on Oh are you being serious or is this
mano trying to get out of there because
he's trying to get you guys to spread
the game is that how this is working I
see through your ruse here oh I see what
you're doing
oh that's what it meant by extended demo
well holy [ __ ] that was just a demo wow
that's a pretty impressive demo when it
usually comes to demos in indie horror
games it's like a 10 minute 15 minute if
that adventure that was like a
full-sized in the aura game and pretty
good too with good animations good
scares a lot of good things going on
here so heck yeah I'm gonna vote for
that on Steam greenlight but bit of a
dickish play standard for me after all
the things I did but either way is still
good so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought of
this down in the comments below this is
pretty good it got me a quite a few
times so let me know if it got you -
thanks get it boy and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]